The four Emperors are the most powerful characters
in all of One Piece. But on top of being
the absolute strongest beings in the world,
they also play an important political role in
balancing the powers of the world. So let’s
break down the complex Emperor system
by discussing its history, its purpose,
who each emperor is, and how they all became
so MIND-BLOWINGLY powerful in the first place.
Starting with the fact that just one of
these RIDICULOUSLY STRONG characters is
enough to make the World Government cry like
a little baby. In fact, when just one of the
Emperors attacked Marine HQ they had to call in
EVERY SINGLE ONE of their strongest fighters to
even have a chance to survive. So you might
be asking yourself, “Well Manu, if these
Emperors are so powerful then why haven’t they
already taken out the World Government?” Which
is an excellent question that I promise we will
answer if you make it to the end of the video.
But first, let’s start with the basics because
in the One Piece World the pirate captains with
the most influence and power are typically
called Emperors of the Sea. At the start of
the story there were four Emperors, who we’ll
talk more about in just a moment. However,
honestly the Emperor system isn’t really an
official organization where the pirates get
together and figure out the strongest
fighters. Instead, it is mostly based
on who the world views as the strongest and most
important pirates. Which isn’t a perfect system,
and can lead to some HILARIOUS MISTAKES,
as we’ll talk about in just a few minutes.
Now we have to keep in mind that these Emperors
are ridiculously powerful on their own,
it usually isn’t enough to just be a ridiculously
powerful fighter on your own. Because what really
puts a character at Emperor Tier is the fact
that they have a ton of super strong allies
and usually rule over important territories
in the most dangerous part of the sea, the
New World. And we’ll talk about the structure of
each of the Emperors’ crews later on, but before
that it is super important to understand
the Emperors’ true purpose in the story.
Because what you might not know is that
although most of the Emperors claim to
be going after the One Piece treasure, their
actual main purpose in the story is basically
to be an obstacle to stop any of the younger
pirates trying to find the One Piece. And
they are able to do this because in order to
find the legendary final island, Laugh Tale,
you need the four of these unbreakable red stones
which will guide you to Laugh Tale. And at the
start of the story, two of these red stones
were held by the Emperor’s Kaido and Big Mom,
which means they are somewhat close to finding
the one piece, although they don’t seem to have
made any progress for decades. That might
be because they rarely come into conflict
with each other because if two Emperors were to
actually go all out and fight, it would leave
both of them extremely weak and vulnerable to
attack from a third Emperor or even the Marines.
So yeah, if you are a young pirate good luck
trying to take out one of these monstrous
fighters. But this is exactly why there
is basically a stalemate in the New World,
where no one is truly making progress
towards the One Piece. I mean the
marines can’t take out the Emperors
without seriously weakening themselves,
young pirates join or get taken out by the
Emperors, and the Emperors themselves don’t
really want to fight each other either.
Which sounds kinda boring but you might
be surprised to learn that this is EXACTLY
how the World Government wants it. No one
makes it any closer to finding the One Piece or
learning the World Government's darkest secrets.
Now I actually just lied when I said that no one
is making progress towards the One Piece, because
if you have been following the story AT ALL then
you know that the main character Luffy is getting
VERY CLOSE to finding the legendary treasure.
And at this point at the end of the Wano arc,
Luffy is officially an Emperor of the Sea - for
real this time. Which actually gave us a true
glimpse at how a character becomes an Emperor
because taking down the Emperor Kadio made it
so the entire world simply had to recognize
him as one of the strongest pirates around.
However, despite what you might think,
defeating one Emperor doesn’t automatically
make the victor the new Emperor. Because when
Blackbeard dealt the final blow to the Emperor
Whitebeard, he wasn’t automatically given Emperor
status. Instead, Blackbeard also had to wipe out
the rest of Whitebeard’s crew during the timeskip
in order to finally be recognized as an Emperor by
the entire world. So again, it is a combination
of super impressive feats against the other
Emperors as well as global acknowledgment
of a pirate being massively influential.
But this system isn’t perfect, because as we
saw when Luffy escaped from Whole Cake Island,
he was called an Emperor even though the other
Emperor’s could tell that he wasn’t strong enough
yet. However, what happened at the end of Wano
was even more hilarious because the newspaper
and World Government started calling Buggy
the Clown a new Emperor as well because of
the simple fact that they think he is the leader
of a group of marine hunting pirates. However,
in reality he is just the figurehead
and the real power is with these two.
So like I said… not a perfect system at all.
What may COMPLETELY SHOCK is that the Emperor
system has probably not existed for very long
at all. I mean we don’t know for sure, but when
people talk about the strongest pirates from the
past, it was usually one or two pirates who were
super strong and were capable of taking over the
world. Specifically I’m talking about forty
years ago with the pirate Rocks D. Xebec, who
was said to be so strong he almost conquered the
world. And after him it was the pirate King Gol
D. Roger’s era, which makes me think that
the Emperors only really became a thing
once Roger started the great pirate era after his
execution twenty-three years ago. Though we don’t
really know, so it’s possible that before
becoming pirate king Roger was considered
an Emperor alongside Whitebeard, Kaido, and
Big Mom, who were all active at the time.
And before we talk more specifically about each
of these LEGENDARY PIRATES, it is super important
to discuss the actual structure of the Emperors’
crews. Because as I said these crews are massive
and most Emperors have multiple islands under
their control. In general, each Emperor will
have a group of INSANELY POWERFUL top commanders
right below them, though this varies with each
Emperor. For example, Kaido has three All-Star
commanders while Shanks has a larger group of nine
Senior Officers. These commander-level crewmates
are usually incredibly powerful on their own,
with each one easily capable of wiping
out entire pirate crews on their own.
Now besides their main crew, each Emperor
typically has allied captains that will come to
fight at their command. This was perfectly shown
in Marineford when Whitebeard’s FORTY-THREE allied
captains came to fight for him. But even one of
the newer Emperors like Blackbeard has allied
pirates working under him, like we saw with this
guy right here. Then of course Luffy has the Straw
Hat Grand Fleet, who are pirates captains who
pledged to come fight for him when he needs help.
And on top of all the strong subordinates, the
Emperor’s usually control one or more islands who
are under their protection. For example, Big Mom
has a whole territory of thirty-five islands which
make up her dream paradise Tott Land. Then we have
Kaido who of course has taken over Wano Country,
but we have also seen he has control of other
random islands. And since these territories
are under the protection of the Emperor, anyone
who attacks them risks becoming a target of the
Emperor’s crew. We saw this during the Fishman
Island arc, which at the time was under Big
Mom’s control, and Luffy’s actions there
made Big Mom instantly label him an enemy.
On the other hand we have characters like this
guy who ransacked one of Shanks’ territories,
and we then later saw Shanks and his crew talking
about getting revenge on this crew. Which at this
point you should know that things are probably
going to end very badly for this ragtag bunch
of Luffy supporters. But you can avoid the same
tragic fate and get on all the Emperors’ good
sides by clicking that nice red subscribe button
to get more one piece content just like this.
Now we cannot talk any more about the Emperors
without discussing the SINGLE BIGGEST CLASH of
Emperor-level characters in the entire story.
Of course, I’m talking about the conflict at
the mysterious island God Valley which happened
forty years ago. And honestly if I had to guess,
this is very likely the birthplace of the
modern Emperor system. Because without
getting into too many details we had
the legendary Rocks D. Xebec who was the
strongest pirate of his era clashing with
the future pirate king, Gol D. Roger. And
while we don’t know if Roger or Rocks were
ever officially called Emperors of the Sea,
I simply had to bring this up because once
Rocks was defeated, his crew separated to form
their own pirate crews. And WOW this completely
changed the world because this group had three
future Emperors including Big Mom, Kaido, AND
Whitebeard. Seriously what an INSANE pirate crew.
And this is the origin of the future World’s
Strongest man, because after this Whitebeard later
went on to be Roger’s greatest rival. But honestly
Whitebeard was the best kind of pirate. Sure he
still stole treasure and smacked down smaller
pirate crews, Whitebeard beats the Spade pirates,
but his true dream was just to have a family of
his own. Which is exactly what ended up happening
because his entire massive crew were basically
like his sons and daughters. Which means he would
do ANYTHING FOR THEM, including enter an all out
war with the marines, just like we saw during the
war at Marineford. Which is still to this day the
most insane war arc I have ever seen, and it was
so epic in large part because Whitebeard is so
stupidly powerful with his Tremor devil fruit
which can literally destroy entire islands.
But Whitebeard wasn’t alone because he also
had his super-sized crew led by the sixteen
division commanders PLUS Forty-Three allied
pirate captains. So clearly he was a beloved
captain who was respected by his crew, allies,
and even older marines like Luffy’s Grandpa,
Garp, and the former Fleet Admiral, Sengoku.
It is also INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT to understand
that each of the Emperors also help us understand
Luffy’s growing strength on his way to become
pirate king. For example, when Luffy met
Whitebeard, he was nowhere near strong enough to
take out the elderly Emperor, but he was able to
earn Whitebeard’s respect which played a huge role
when the Emperor’s crew helped Luffy later on.
Which makes it completely mind-blowing that we
can have well respected Emperors like Whitebeard,
but then have straight up evil Emperors like
Kaido. And as we see all throughout the Wano arc,
this man is power hungry and battle crazy.
In fact, it is his dream to die a spectacular
death just like his former Captain Rocks or even
Whitebeard. But this man takes this wish WAY TOO
FAR because he would literally destroy the entire
world just to find a strong fighter to satisfy his
insane wish. And the worst part is that he could
probably do it because he is just stupidly strong.
Even in his base form he was powerful enough
to join Rocks’ crew as a teenager AND THEN he
got his legendary devil fruit which gives him
the powers of a mythical dragon. But if that’s
not enough he also has some of the STRONGEST haki
that we have seen in the entire story. Seriously,
sometimes I STILL WONDER how Luffy was
able to beat this guy. And in fact,
it was by beating Kaido that Luffy truly
became one of the Emperors of the Sea,
which we’ll talk more about in just a moment.
But of course Kaido doesn’t fight alone. His
crew is made up of thousands of random pirates
alongside purely animal zoan devil fruit users.
Which includes awesome dinosaur fruits, and
also the super weird smile fruit users which,
if you’re lucky, give you some random animal
part on your body. However, Kaido’s crew is
not the loving family that Whitebeard’s was
because Kaido actively encourages his strongest
subordinates to fight in order to take one of the
top three All-Star commander ranks of the crew.
What’s even crazier though is that Kaido almost
got his wish of destroying the world when he
teamed up with Big Mom during the Wano arc. Now
before this alliance these two actually hated each
other for years, but there is no denying that
Big Mom, whose real name is Charlotte Linlin,
is a monstrous fighter just like Kaido. She was
also a part of the infamous Rocks crew from a
young age, but what’s even more impressive is
that she took out an entire village of giants
at just five years old. I mean, come on. That’s
just ridiculous. And ever since then she’s had
the god-like powers of the soul devil fruit,
which let her take the life-span of people
and turn objects into living things. Plus,
as we saw during the Whole Cake Island Arc,
she also has all three forms of haki which
meant that when Luffy snuck in to steal her
Road Poneglyph and get his cook back, he could
not seriously fight with her because he just
wasn’t strong enough yet. Which meant that Luffy
instead had to defeat her strongest son, Katakuri,
in order for the rest of the straw hats to
escape the island. And that’s honestly one
of the most interesting things about Big
Mom’s crew, is that it is literally made
up of her son’s and daughters. All Eighty-Five
children AND forty three husbands. Sheesh. Big
Mom indeed. She’s basically having kids every
year. But does that mean she is constantly
pregnant? Uh, actually, I don’t really want to
know. However, it kinda makes sense because ever
since Big Mom was abandoned as a child, her true
goal was to create a paradise where all the races
of the world could live together peacefully.
Which she kinda did with Tott Land, except that
she was stealing everyone’s souls and anyone
who pissed her off would be killed. So yeah,
not exactly paradise, but more like a twisted
version of the free world Luffy wants to bring.
However, all three of the Emperors we’ve
discussed so far have been killed or defeated,
which means they have lost
their status as Emperors.
Which takes us to the first of the current Emperor
we are going to discuss who has actually made
his own pirate paradise by becoming the ruler of
Pirate Island. This is of course Blackbeard, who
became an Emperor during the timeskip by defeating
the remainder of Whitebeard’s crew. And out of any
pirate in the entire story, he has caused the MOST
chaos in the entire world by killing Whitebeard,
breaking world-class criminals out of the prison
to form his ridiculously strong pirate crew,
and stealing ridiculously powerful devil fruits
to give to himself and the crew. In fact,
he is THE ONLY PERSON that we know
of to have eaten two devil fruits,
including his Darkness fruit and Whitebeard’s old
Tremor fruit. Seriously, this guy is insane. And
on top of all of this, his dream is to become king
of the world, which means that he is Luffy’s main
rival to become pirate king and these two will
undoubtedly be clashing in the story very soon.
But speaking of Luffy, his path to becoming
Emperor was honestly the most difficult out
of anyone. He had to defeat Kaido plus go
through Big Mom during the Wano arc. And
he did all this to help his friends, which
is the true essence of Luffy’s dream. Yes,
we all know that he wants to be pirate king,
but that is only because he wants freedom
for him and his friends. He has achieved
all of this with the help of his god-like
devil fruit and by learning all three types of
advanced haki. So truly he is worthy of being
called an Emperor. Plus of course, he has his
crew which are incredibly strong in their own
right and as the Straw Hat Grand Fleet who
will come fight for him when he needs them.
Now while you might think this next Emperor is
a joke, I am here to tell you that Emperor Buggy
should be taken VERY SERIOUSLY as a threat
to become pirate king. That’s because he
recently became an Emperor as the “leader”
of the Cross Guild group which hunts down
marines for bounties. But even though
he isn’t individually all that strong,
he has an incredible amount of influence in the
pirate world. That’s because for whatever reason
he is always able to inspire pirates to do what
he wants, which includes tricking much stronger
pirates to fight for him. And at this point he
has the World's strongest Swordsman and a former
Warlord of the Sea on his side, so yeah Emperor
Buggy is no laughing matter. Honestly though,
I have no clue if he will be Luffy’s ally or
enemy by the end of the story, but I wouldn’t
be surprised if he is actually considered King
of the Pirates at the very end of the story.
Which of course leaves us with Red Hair Shanks,
who in my opinion is the STRONGEST CURRENT
Emperor, and despite being Luffy’s hero from the
start of the story, he could actually end up being
a rival to become pirate king. Now we do know
that Shanks became an Emperor only six years ago,
but it is only now that Luffy has defeated Kaido
that he is truly starting his pursuit of the One
Piece treasure. Which might have been his dream
all along, and if this is the case then he is
going to be a MAJOR THREAT because we have been
told by none other than the marines that Shanks
has the MOST BALANCED core crew out of any of the
Emperors with high average bounties and ABSOLUTELY
NO weak spots. So yeah, good luck taking out
the Red Hair Pirates. But what’s even crazier
is that it is very likely Shanks’ crew will fight
in some way against the straw hat since they have
very similar roles on the crew such as first
mate, sniper, navigator, musician, and so on.
Which means that Shanks and his crew are just
one of the possible end game opponents for Luffy,
but perhaps the more likely option is not a
pirate at all but instead the ENTIRE Marine and
World Government forces. Because there is NO WAY
the POWERHOUSE fighters like the Marine Admirals
will just let Luffy find the One Piece and CHANGE
THE WORLD without a fight. And if you want to know
exactly all of the INSANE marines from cadets all
the way up to the strongest officers that they
will be sending to stop Luffy, you can watch my
breakdown of the entire Marine System right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.